Tony Dungy on loan from NBC the football
night in America program Continental
Tire coaches corner and coach to insist
on good morning coach how are you hey
Dan good morning in McClellan's right
that October heat in Florida can
definitely be an advantage to the home
team were familiar with that are the
Dolphins are they good are they average
I I don't know right and I were talking
about that on the show last night when
you get past Kansas City in New England
who's good in the AFC and the thing
about it you have to in this day and age
as I'm looking at it you have to be good
on offense you have to be consistently
good on offense to have a chance and I
don't know who that is in the AFC I
think the Chargers are better than the
Chiefs because that charger defense is a
whole lot better than Kansas City's and
I don't know if the offense is that far
off Kansas City's and I would say that
the Chargers are probably a more
well-rounded team than the Chiefs your
thoughts they probably are but in this
day and age you're winning with hot
offense I mean you look at these teams
are winning even the Rams are playing
okay on defense they're making big plays
when they need to do that they're not
great on defense
it's you go out there and out score
people but Ken can is this going to be
the game plan for Kansas City the rest
of the season I think it is and you know
you look at it they they have a couple
of passes Justin Juicin was out last
night so that really took a big weapon
away from them but they don't have
coverage guys they don't have
linebackers where they can go out and
consistently stop people so it is
they're gonna have no score people and
it does remind me of their old three
season when they had that great offense
these homes and Trent Green and they
really had a struggling defense I look
at the Patriots tone and you coached
against him but I always thought that
Belichick looked at the month of
September like it was their preseason
and then after that he sort of had an
idea of how he was going to adjust when
he needed to adjust add subtract and now
once October starts you start to see
more of what New England will be like
for the rest of the season do you think
that's a game plan
many that he has or is that just me
reading into it a little too much no I
think you're absolutely right I don't
think he cares about losing James in
September he's trying to teach them how
to play he's kind of teaching them
philosophy he's trying to find out what
some certain guys can do and if he loses
to Detroit in September I don't think he
really cares because he was figured out
they'll learn some lessons and then
they'll play well down the stretch I
think you're exactly right
what would you force my homes into doing
if you're a defense if you have you know
this the players to be able to do it you
can have a game plan but if you don't
have the players it doesn't matter but
you being a defensive minded guy what
would what would you have done as a head
coach I would really try to take that
deep ball big strike away from him
they pressed him a little bit last night
that could be feast or famine because he
can run around and make plays but I
would play three dudes own and not let
Tyreke Hill gets those seven er plays
not but you know make them have to make
10 or 12 plays to score and see if you
could do that only consistent basis we
saw a little different wrinkle to the
Cowboys yesterday dominating the Jags
and I don't know if you can implement
this on a weekly basis but I do like the
run-pass option with dak because I don't
know if he's I don't know if he's
consistent enough to be just a pocket
passer I think that he has to almost put
pressure on you in a variety of ways
what did you make of that game plan I
totally agree I thought they had a great
plan you know try and hit the comments
with Scott letting him to do some
different things with the Cowboys on
some good cruelty and I think you have
to you have to look at what they have
they don't have a great receiving corps
they have a dynamic back home
they have a mobile quarterback so use
that use the running game both legs
the rpoS let him make easy thrown and
build it around in the running game I
thought they were very creative and I
thought they did a good job last night
what happened to Jacksonville
back-to-back weeks here
you know I think it's playing on the
Rumble number one not having that home
crowd in the ways that takes a little
bit away from you and playing mobile
quarterbacks they tee off on people that
can sit in the pocket when they know
you're going to be seven yards deep
they have a lot of weapons to come after
you but the fact that they didn't know
where my homes was going to be
necessarily they didn't know where Jack
was going to be that slowed their rush
down and as much as Julian Ramsey wants
to think they've got great cover guys
back there their defense was built on
the RUS yeah I just you know and then
jaylen Ramsey who you know loves finding
the microphone had nothing to say after
refused to talk about anything there and
I just it seems like it's a little
tricky there with Jacksonville no for
net you still had the Blake bortles
situation cuz that's you know you're not
sure what you're getting week to week
not have Annette really hurts Blake
bortles because again just like with the
Cowboys when you're going to play Dallas
you're going to take away is they kill
Elliott that's their game plan when you
go into play Jacksonville you and take
away Leonard fournette
unless he's not in there yeah now all of
a sudden you've seen different coverages
you aren't seeing eight-man front what
you got easy one on one throw so not
have important that really puts a lot
more pressure on on bortles and I think
that's why we stand these up and down
performances when when that gets back
they're able to pound the ball and
everybody says okay we got to go back to
stopping that inside run game you'll see
portals put up better numbers he's Tony
Dungy NBC football night in America
hall-of-famer joining us Dan Patrick
show would you consider this is this out
of the question that the Jags would call
the Giants and just ask about Eli
Manning given Tom Coughlin's
relationship with Eli what do you think
of that possibility you know it I think
they believe in Blake bortles I really
do I think they feel like when they've
got their formula there they don't need
Eli Tom Coughlin's might prevent that it
might be a win-win situation for both
team yeah it would help the Giants out
and it probably would help the Jag
though I'm just wondering about that
because
I look at the AFC you know the NFC
you've got the Rams are great the Saints
are very good who else would you throw
in there in the NFC I think Minnesota
and Green Bay has the potential to be
good when Rodgers is 100% healthy
but again I look at this link the way of
school and now you've got to play
offense and you got to be dynamic you
know that the Carolina Panthers getting
to the Super Bowl with a great defense
and spotty all offense
Seattle's getting there with those great
defenses Denver getting there and
winning it with a great defense I just
don't see that happening any more I look
at Pittsburgh Mike Tomlin is a very good
defensive coach New England Bill
Belichick is a very good defensive coach
these guys don't have good defenses no
you know what if we can't win that way
anymore we've got to put all the money
on offense we've got to get weapons
we've got to outscore people and you're
just saying it all over and and I think
that's what you have to do you've got to
get a quarterback that can make plays
and you got to be able to put points on
the board if you want to be a contender
and I just don't see that many dynamic
offenses in the AFC well what's that
being said with the baggage that Le'Veon
Bell would bring into the Steelers do
you need him if you're going to be one
of those teams I think they do they're
getting great play out of James Conner
but he's still not Le'Veon Bell and the
way their defense is they are going to
have to put up a ton of points if they
play in New England or Kansas City
we already slowed that against Kansas
City they couldn't keep up with them
scoring New England will be the same way
so they need Le'Veon Bell they need that
extra kick in November and December to
give them another weapon I think they
need him but how do you use him Tony if
he's oh he's gonna be counting his
touches as if to say hey here's a
magical number I don't want to go above
that because I want to protect my body
so I get another contract with another
team like that yeah that's the tough
thing I don't know that you can play
with a guy who's got that attitude it
just wouldn't be good either Jimmy
poppers
raishin in in football so I don't know
what you do but I think they need him if
they're gonna bid the AFC champions but
would you want him if your Mike Tomlin
we may need him yeah but I don't know if
it could even work yeah I still get the
feeling he's gonna be traded I and I
mean maybe I'm naive on it I just it
feels like even if he comes and it's
just gonna be weird when he comes in
because I don't know if he's gonna sit
out a game because he may not be
injuried may just say you know what I
don't want play and then we won't know
no there was somebody that would take
him and feel like he would add just what
they need to be that dynamic offense so
I think that trade is possibility tone
good to talk to you tell Rodney and the
boys I said hello and we'll talk to you
soon all right
that's Tony Dungy football night in
America I just I still feel like the
Steelers are gonna move in but I don't I
don't know what the asking price is
we've been told that Buffalo is asking
price for labia on bail or LeSean McCoy
hi and that's LeSean McCoy Continental
Tire Coaches Corner and brings you Tony
Dungy for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]